>> Male Presenter: Hi. Good morning. My name
is Kevin Wang from 141.
Thank you all for coming. You know, we have
lots of
chess players here. Also lots of chess players
in 141. Today
it's our honor to have Dr. James Magner here
to talk
about his new book. Also share his advice.
And
Dr. Magner is a scientist, a doctor, husband,
father, investor, and
a chess player. He went through college, medical
school,
married and raised a family. And still was
able to get in
some serious chess playing. His new book,
which you have
now, and provide help to readers who want
to live rich and meaningful
lives who also want to win more chess games.
[laughter] Without
further ado, let's welcome James.
>> Dr. Magner: Thank you very much. So I'm
really -- I'm really
happy to be here. It's a real privilege for
me to be
here because I know how skilled and creative
people at
Google are. I had a problem. I was busy with
my career
and you know going to medical school and so
on. I wanted
to meet girls, okay? I wanted to do something
meaningful
with my career. And I wanted to, you know,
I was
ambitious. I wanted to get a good job that
had good pay
and benefits. I didn't want to be totally
materialistic,
but I recognized I had to earn a living, pay
a mortgage,
buy shoes for children. And so, all of that
is important
to keep in mind. But I wanted to keep interests.
I'm an
amateur astronomer. I collect fossils. I was
in Boy Scouts so I had those interests. And
I, even though I
was an adult, I wanted to keep some of those
interests.
And then, over the years, I accumulated lots
of stories,
because I raised two daughters, I had interesting,
difficult patients. I had various crises as
we all do.
And I saw that there was, in medicine sometimes
people get
burned out and sort of cynicism in medicine.
And I
wanted to share some of my stories because
sort of as a
positive message for medical students and
trainees that
you have to keep your eye on many different
things but
enjoy your life and do something productive
and be a good
citizen and, you know, have fun. And how could
I share
some of those anecdotes and stories? Because
I'm not
Henry Kissinger and so nobody is going to
pay to publish
my stories, which I thought were valuable.
In other
words, I felt I had a message or interesting
and
actually. Nobody wants to read a long, dull,
book so I
wanted to do something that was entertaining
and useful.
In other words anecdotes could be instructive
and
entertaining and useful. Who's going to do
it? Well, I
was an amateur chess player. Now, I'm an average
player
that plays in tournaments. So of people that
pay 50
dollars to sign up in a tournament, I'm sort
of average
in that -- so my rating is like 15/50, okay?
So and part
of my problem over the years is I never had
time to study
chess, really. So I decided over the years
I would
collect little traps and tricks I could use
occasionally to beat
really strong players. And it was fun. Although
I would
usually lose to strong players. [laughter]
To occasionally surprise
one of them and beat them. So I thought what
I'll do,
since I played for 40 years, that I would
collect some
of these games where I actually tricked somebody
that was
hundreds of points better than me. It can
happen. And
put those together. And then, interweave my,
the
things that I really wanted to publish, which
are my
anecdotes. And have a chess publisher publish
it and
then that way I wouldn't have to pay. Because
if you
publish your own book it's like 20,000 dollars.
Maybe
electronic publishing is cheaper now. But
I wanted
actually a book. I'm my age if I'm going to
publish a
book, I want a book. So I thought, "how could
I get this
done?" So to make a long story short, I sent
out samples
to three chess publishers, one of them in
New Haven, who is
a prominent chess publisher. Sent me a response,
"it's an intriguing -- some intriguing material
-- come
meet me on Saturday morning; we'll talk about
it." So
that morning I put on my necktie. I had coffee
with my
wife and she said, "Jim I just want to protect
your ego because
this is a chess publisher. He's going to tell
you
you're an average player. You have a very
creative, like a
tricky style, so it's kind of, you have some
intriguing games. But you're kind of an average
player.
But all this other crap has to come out. [laughter]
And so, I said,
"well, we'll see what happens." So I met with
the
publisher and he said, "well, Jim you have
an intriguing
style. You have tricks and traps. You beat
some strong
players. But basically you're an average player.
You
probably have too many games. Take some of
the games
out. [audience chuckles] But put in some more
of these stories, because
those anecdotes are great, okay? [laughter]
So that's the kind of
publisher I really needed to meet. So his
name is Hanon
Russell. And he's published many chess books
over the
last 30 years in the United States. So he
committed the
money. Actually, he gave me a 1-page contracted
saying
he was going to get 90 percent, I'm going
to get 10
percent. So I said, "let me -- I played chess
for 40
years, I wrote up the games, I wrote up my
stories. You
publish it and you get 90 percent and I get
10 percent."
And he said yes. Because of course, he's putting
up the
money -- he has to earn his money back. And
I said,
"sold." [laughter] Signed it. So that was
-- I mean,
so I want to make clear at the very beginning
-- I'm not
here to try to sell anything really or to,
I'm not
doing this to make money. I feel I have a
valuable
message especially more young medical trainees
or
actually any bright college age person or
professional. I hope that
you'll actually. You can skip the chess parts.
If
you'll actually look at it over the holidays,
it's
entertaining and I think you'll take something
away from it.
So I'm just going to read some excerpts if
that's the way
you usually do this. And also, this is very
informal.
So you are welcome to contact me later. I
work at
Genzyme down the street. I'm an endocrinologist.
But I
mostly sit at a computer all day. You know
what that's
like, doing clinical research documents. So
in the
introduction, I talk about the development
of expertise
in an area such as skill playing chess. Is
that the result of
innate talent or is that a skill even an average
person
can achieve if enough hours of study and practice
were
applied? Intuitively many persons believe
that innate
talent as well as practice are required. There's
a guy
named Philip Ross who came up with a 10,000
hour rule, a
hypothesis much discussed in recent years,
that states
that a bright person who wants to have a skill
in some
area need only study and practice that skill
for 10,000
hours to achieve a very high level of expertise.
Let me
now do a calculation. Assuming a person has
a spouse and
a family as well as a job and other responsibilities,
one
might potentially only be able to study or
play chess for
one Saturday afternoon for four hours at most.
That
would commit 2500 Saturdays or 48 years before
one would
achieve expertise in chess if the 10,000 hour
rule is
valid. And that can be a discouraging realization
although I thought it was probable, I suppose,
that after
only 1,000 hours some people may be reasonably
good. So
other people have thought about this too.
Charles
Krauthammer who's sometimes on TV, a very
smart man. He
wrote a review -- a little article -- in the
New Republic
in July 1983 called "Joy and Madness at the
Board: the romance of
chess". And he quoted at the beginning of
his article HG
Wells. You have, let us say, a promising politician,
a
rising artist that you wish to destroy. Dagger
or bomb
are archaic, clumsy, and unreliable. But teach
him,
inoculate him with chess, so that's the way
to destroy
your enemy. For Wells, chess was not just
an addiction,
its continuing popularity constituted a kind
of heresy. Wells wrote, quote, "The
passion for playing chess is one of the most
unaccountable in the world. It slaps the theory
of
natural selection in the face. [laughter]
It is the most absorbing
of occupations, the least satisfying of desires.
It
annihilates a man". So Krauthammer humorously
speculated
that Well's ire had been formed at an impressionable
age
when he left a rook hanging in an important
game and he
postulated that Wells never quite recovered.
So could
be. So one of my themes in the book is that
you need to
have hobbies like chess, but don't get so
addicted or
taken by whether it's swimmer or running or
whatever your
hobby is. You do need to keep balance. You
have
families, you have children, you have careers,
you have
other important interests perhaps with your
church or
certain charities. And we -- Kevin and I -- when
we go
to the chess tournaments, I think we see some
rather odd
people there sometimes who have spent 40 hours
a week
playing chess. And like they barely have enough
money to
buy groceries,I think. And so, it's -- one
can take
things a little bit too far. And also probably
the new
addiction might be Texas Hold'em poker, which
I also enjoy
playing, but I see some of these people at
poker
tournaments who probably dig ditches for a
living and for them $100 to sit down and play
in a poker tournament, that's a lot of money
for them.
And they're not thinking clearly in terms
of the way
they're investing their time. I did well in
school and
it's important for the people still in college
who might
read this to have the priority to do well
in school. And
I won a scholarship to come over to Woods
Hole, Massachusetts to do
biology studies for a summer in 1972. That
was the era of,
you know, a little wildness and free love
and all that
stuff. I was just in college, at the summer
experience,
sort of a long way from home in Illinois.
I was a good
boy, okay? But it was a coming of age experience
for me
that summer. And I'll read you one anecdote.
During the
summer of 1972, after my junior year in college,
I was
awarded a small scholarship to live and study
in Woods Hole, Massachusetts. I
was to take the summer biology course and
complete a
well-defined research project in a few weeks.
if possible.
I joined a group of a dozen bright students
from around
the U.S.. We had a great time added both at
work and play.
During the first week, Dr. Janish invited
the students to spend an informal evening
at his home. We
had some lively discussions about biology,
sciences and Woods Hole when at about 1030
p.m., one of the young ladies from California
stood up and
shouted, "let's go skinny dipping." Everyone
immediately
agreed and we raced out the front door to
the nearby beach.
Although I'll admit that this shy and studious
boy from
Illinois, -- land of endless corn fields--,
was trailing in the
rear and was quite bemused by this sudden
turn of events.
And so, that was one of my first quite memorable
experiences.
And of course, we did good science at Woods
Hole also. [laughter] In the book --
I've been interested in human evolution, in
genetics
for a number of years. I put some material
in the book
about that as well. And I talk about DNA and
sort of
like you, probably most educated laypersons
know. That
all of us share almost identical DNA sequences.
Of
course the police can track down criminals
by the
occasional differences in certain areas. But
like on
page 31, I mention that, "if the long strings
of the DNA
letter sequences from any two persons were
set side by
side and compared, about 999 out of every
1,000 letters would be
exactly the same in the two sequences. Of
the
approximately 3 billion letters in each long
string, the
inheritable differences in each person thus
would consist
of just 0.1 percent of the sequence. In contrast,
chimpanzees are approximately 7 to 10 times
more genetically diverse.
Moreover, the genetic differences between
a chimpanzee
and a human are 20 times greater than the
differences
between two average humans even though the
overall DNA
sequence of an average chimpanzee is about
98.5 percent
identical to that of an average human. The
high
similarity of the DNA sequences among individual
people
is evidence that all humans descended from
a relatively
small group of ancestors perhaps because many
thousands
of years ago the human population went through
a
so-called bottleneck because of famine or
disease or lack
of resources. The bottleneck concept would
be more
believable if our ancestors were living in
a relatively
small region so that a famine, for example,
could affect an entire
location where the ancestors lived. Intriguingly
our direct
ancestors possibly moved out of Africa about
50,000 to
100,000 years ago after stopping for awhile
in the Middle
East and then they spread over a wide area.
They
followed in the footsteps of other hominids
who had
exited Africa in prior waves of migration.
And these
earlier human-like creatures who had migrated
out earlier
shared a common ancestor with us, but the
ones who had
immigrated earlier from Africa were not, for
the most part,
our direct ancestors. In fact, there may have
been a
little breeding between these separate groups
under special
circumstances. And then I mention in the next
paragraph
an intriguing theory by Huff and all from
University of
Utah. They looked at so-called mobile elements
in the
DNA and they found that about a million years
ago there
were -- based on their mathematical calculations
-- there
were only about 18,500 animals that were human.
So we
came from a very, very limit -- small group.
And that's
sort of an intriguing story. In medical school,
that was
also a coming of life experience. And I only
played a
little chess in medical school. I'd been an
Eagle Scout
in my hometown of Quincy. So as part of my
scouting
experience, I learned to shoot a small caliber
rifle.
But I'd never seen a gunshot wound. Many patients
with
knife and gunshot wounds were brought to the
emergency
room at the University of Chicago where I
went to medical
school. And one evening, as I was following
a surgical
resident around on call, his beeper went off
and he was asked to
come to the ER right away to see a young man
who had been
shot. I road down the elevator with the resident
and I
was rather uncomfortable. So I was still a
medical
student then. Because I had no idea what this
was going
to be like. The two of us were directed to
an
examination room and I held my breath as we
stepped through the
door. There on the exam table sat a 25-year-old
man
looking more annoyed than traumatically injured.
He wore
a bright purple vest over a lime green shirt
and sported
a large gray felt hat with a small orange
feather on one
side. He looked up at us and pointed at his
left thigh.
The nurses had removed his pants and had applied
pressure
bandages where a small caliber bullet had
entered and
also exited his thigh. We unwrapped the bandages
to
examine the small tears in the skin where
the bullet had
passed clean through. After a brief medical
history, the
resident showed me how he could tell the path
of the
bullet had not hit the bone. The pulses in
the leg were
normal and the neurologic examination of the
leg also was
completely normal. As I watched with a suppressed
smile,
the resident expertly applied a band aid to
both the
entrance and exit wounds, shook the man's
hand and
pointed him to the checkout desk. So that
was the first
gunshot wound I ever saw. Then I'll just quickly
add.
Sadly, not all of my experiences with gunshot
wound
patients were as lighthearted. By the time
of my fourth
year, surgical rotation, I'd established myself
as a
smart student who was very precise, well organized
and
highly competent. But unfortunately in the
eyes of my
surgeon supervisors, clearly inclined to internal
medicine instead of surgery. They brought
me one evening
to the surgical intensive care unit where
a middle-aged woman lay
intubated on a respirator with multiple IV
lines, a Foley
catheter, a chest tube etcetera, etcetera.
She had been shot in the
chest and abdomen four times by her husband
and had been
stabilized in surgery that day. The surgeons
told me to
watch her all the night, keep track of all
the central
lines, IVs, medications, blood transfusions,
urine flow,
chest tube output, vital signs, respiratory
settings,
blood gases, etcetera. And give them a call
if I had any serious
problems. I was thrilled -- so fourth year
student -- I
was thrilled by this opportunity to manage
a complicated
and very ill patient along with the skilled
nursing staff
and characteristically and quite understandably
the
surgeons were thrilled to leave these medical
tasks to a
bright student so that they could get back
to the
operating room. Different people are just
naturally
inclined to different sorts of challenges.
All went well
until midnight when a hospital security officer
peeked
into the intensive care unit to see me. "Hey
Doc. Got
to talk to you," he whispered. And although
I was wearing
a white coat, I was not a doctor, just a fourth
year
student. We just got a call that this lady's
husband
found out she is still alive so he's grabbed
his gun and
is on the way to the hospital to finish her
off. "Oh", I
replied numbly while holding two clipboards
and three
flowcharts. [clears throat] "Just wanted to
let you know,Doc, so you can
be ready if the man comes in here." [laughter]He
shrugged and then added,
"the chief asked me to sit down the hall for
a couple of
hours so I'll be here." Not feeling much better
about the
security situation, I kept the IV's running,
the blood
transfusing, the chest tube draining, the
respirator
pumping, the urine flowing and the blood pressure
stable
all night until I was relieved in the morning.
The angry
husband never showed up. So that's another
story. We
also took care of indigent patients in Chicago.
And some
of them were alcoholics, criminals, down and
out people.
And they would lose weight, become malnourished
and some
of them would get tuberculosis. So we took
care of them.
On one occasion, a young physician was visiting
from
England and he walked -- we walked him around
the ward.
While standing at the bedside, I presented
to him a case
of a man who was improving on anti-tuberculosis
medications. The young doctor was incredulous
that we
were still seeing cases of TB, commonly, in
the United
States since during his training he had not
seen one case
in England. I explained that our impoverished
urban
areas still had malnourished or alcoholic
or other down
and out persons with TB. With typical British
humor he
responded adamantly, "not in our slums." So
it was
interesting to go to medical school in an
urban area
dealing with all sorts of people, but still
not too much
time for chess. But I was beginning to realize
a few
basic principles about chess as I was playing
people. One needs to gain a a reasonable understanding
of the basic chess openings and focus on about
a half
dozen openings for more careful study. You
can't learn
every opening. So with the limited time that
we have in
our lives to do a hobby like chess, you need
to be
selective and focus on just certain parts
of it. In
addition to just a few openings, you need
to gain insight
into important chess techniques. The most
important
techniques probably are practicing king and
pawn endings,
typical mating nets of the way certain pieces
come
together, let's say against the castled king.
Proper use
of the rooks which even top experts make mistakes
when
you're down to just a king and couple pawns
and a rook on the
board. So there are definite sort of physiological
rules
the way those rooks and pawns interact and
it's very,
if you know those, sometimes a good player
will not be
optimally positioning those rooks and you
can beat them.
You should keep a record of tournament games
and study
those games. You can play over famous games
in chess
history. That's always fun to do. You should
get
adequate sleep and avoid alcohol the night
before a
tournament. Learn some opening traps both
for black and
white and be boldfaced enough to actually
try them during
important games. So I have 31 games in here.
Many of
them I won by an opening trap. And it's embarrassing
to
the opponent if you can beat them in 15 or
20 moves.
Especially if they're a whole lot stronger
than you are.
It's because they underestimated you. You
surprise them.
They weren't ready for it. You need to. We
play with
clocks of course, so you manage your time
well in the
games. Because, if you don't do that, you
don't really have
time to properly think at the critical end
stage of the
game. Have discipline and remain highly attentive
during
games to watch for small errors or inaccuracies
by
opponents. Consider carefully when it may
be to your
advantage to trade off queens and other pieces
to take
dangerous weapons out of your opponent's hands
and so on.
And so, why try some of these -- I'm not reading
them
all, but why try some of these trappy, tricky
plays? It's
because against a very strong opponent you're
going to
lose anyway. [laughter] So you might as well
try something a little
bit unusual. If you're playing somebody your
own
strength, you should probably be very disciplined
and
play really the most correct way that you
can. But if you're
playing somebody hundreds of points higher
be a little
creative because you're probably going to
lose the game
anyway. Accept the fact that you will lose
to a strong
opponent in any case and you are trying a
somewhat
desperate strategy to win the game. Keep in
mind Teddy
Roosevelt's observation. Quote, "Far better
it is" -- you can
almost see him saying this -- "far better
it is to dare
mighty things, to win glorious triumphs even
though
checkered by failure than to rank with those
poor spirits
who neither enjoy nor suffer much because
they live in
the gray twilight that knows neither victory
nor defeat".
Well, I finish my medical school and then
I had met a
girl. She was from Texas. So I decided to
do my
internship and residency in San Antonio. So
we loaded up
her car and drove to Texas. So on Page 48,
I talk about
that little trip. Things were looking up.
I was
finishing medical school in 1977. I was engaged
to be
married that summer. I also had been accepted
at my
first choice hospital for internship in internal
medicine. The drive went well till we were
about 30
miles outside Little Rock, Arkansas. We were
on the
4-lane highway and the Charger started coughing
and
losing power. So Glenda pulled it over to
the side of
the highway. We sat stunned for a moment as
cars and
trucks whizzed by, each one slightly rocking
our stalled
car. It was still light although dusk was
coming. And
there were pine trees as far as we could see.
We stood
outside the car and I raised the hood. Of
course, this
was before cell phones. 1977. For several
minutes, the
cars sped by, but after a quarter hour, one
old small
station wagon passed us but slowed, pulled
to our side of
the highway, then backed up 50 yards to reach
us where we
were parked. A clean cut man in his 30s walked
back
toward us. "Out of gas?" he asked. "No, the
car just lost
power," I replied, "so I guess we're going
to need a tow
truck." We shook hands and I was certainly
glad he had
stopped. He said to grab anything valuable
out of the
car and then, and he would give us a ride
to the next
exit where he thought there was a filling
station and
someone could probably arrange for a tow from
there. He
smiled then handed me a newspaper he carried
with him. A
pro-communist newspaper with a hammer and
sickle in the
top corner. "I also want to give you this,"
he said
earnestly, "and I really want you to read
it and think
about it." I was now more stunned than when
the car had
died. I realized that I was in the woods in
Arkansas
talking to someone who should be feeling a
little out of
place in this county. But I took the newspaper,
thanked
him, and when I reached into the Charger to
collect a
small travel bag, I tossed the newspaper into
the
backseat. The ride to the exit took less than
three
minutes and we hopped out of the filling station
and
waved good-bye and I really did appreciate
his help. The
station owner said we were in luck since Merle
was just
bringing the tow truck into the shop right
now and he
would be happy to tow us into a place he knew
in Little
Rock that could fix our Dodge. In a half hour,
a very
large tow truck pulled in, driven by a very
muscular young
man. I helped Glenda up the high step into
the front
seat next to the driver and then I stepped
up, slid on to
the seat, shut the door. Off we went to retrieve
our
sick car. Merle told us to take any other
valuables out
of the car since he would drop the car at
the dealership
then drop us at a nearby motel. This time
when I reached
into the Charger, I had a couple of minutes
to stuff the
communist newspaper into one of my small bags
out of
sight. I didn't want that in the car where
the workmen
might see it. Merle raised the front wheels
of the
charger and hooked it up. We climbed back
into the front
seat and off we went to Little Rock. It was
now dark.
In a couple of minutes I realized we were
going about 85
miles per hour. I looked back and yes our
car was still
dragging along behind. Next I realized in
the dashboard
in front of our driver was a large black pistol
without a
holster and next to that was a 3-inch stack
of bills
secured with a couple of rubber bands. "I
guess you are
ready for any trouble," I said in a loud voice
to be heard
above the roar of the truck as I pointed at
the gun.
"Yep", said Merle. "Okay if I put on the radio?
My
favorite show is on now," he added. Not being
in an
argumentative mood, I agreed and he clicked
the button.
The church choir was just starting "Holy,
Holy, Holy" and
Merle turned the volume up higher as the engine
roared.
I think he also picked up the pace to 90 miles
an hour.
Our car, remarkably, was still attached. The
next few
minutes were quite memorable as we raced along
the
highway in the dark swerving around slower
traffic, with
the gospel choir on the radio at full blast.
Soon we
were at the dealership where we dropped the
car by the
front door. A few blocks away at the motel
we bid
farewell to Merle with our sincere thanks
and a small tip
since at that point we barely had any money
in our
checking accounts. Merle did his job well
and he did it
in style -- Arkansas style. The next afternoon,
we had a
repaired car and an interesting story to tell.
So that
was my adventure with Merle. I put in a chapter
about my
first daughter. Having children is wonderful.
There can
be surprises. So show of hands. Do some of
you have
kids? So, okay great. So there's always surprises.
So
I'll just read a little bit from Chapter 7.
Erin was
born at the Bethesda Naval Hospital in Maryland
in
January 1981. Glenda and I had joked. Remember
I said
January. Glenda and I had joked somewhat nervously
about
what might happen if she were in labor just
before or
during Super Bowl. But actually, all went
well that day.
Glenda had to stay in the hospital an extra
day because
of a low grade fever which gave me an opportunity
to
speak again with the pediatrician who had
briefly
examined our baby. I told him that I was a
bit of a nervous
new father and I was not highly trained in
pediatrics so
I asked him, please, to re-examine our little
girl one more time
very carefully. That way I would know that
when I got
her home if she was cranky or had some other
issue I
would be more certain that the root cause
was not really
a major problem. He laughed and agreed and
all was well.
We brought our baby back to our apartment
on the third
day after her birth but she didn't take her
breast-feedings very eagerly and she slept
quietly most
of the time. Others commented how lucky we
were to have
a quote good baby. When she was ten days old,
I came home
from work and found Glenda crying because
the baby again
had seem to not take to breast-feedings very
well and was
fussy and crying. Over the course of the evening,
I took
a look at the baby more with a doctor's eye
than a
father's eye but I knew little about babies.
I was
certain that she had been very carefully examined
twice
about a week ago by the pediatrician. But
by 10 p.m., I
noted that her respiratory rate had increased
and she
started having what are called rib retractions.
And
early physical sign of difficult breathing.
I told
Glenda I might be overreacting but I thought
there were
objective signs of a respiratory problem and
I suggested
we take the baby to the emergency room. When
we arrived
at the emergency room, the staff was responsible
enough
to take a look at Erin within just a minute
or two and
they immediately felt there was some sort
of important
respiratory problem. During the next 60 minutes,
her
respiratory problem worsened rapidly and Erin
was
intubated and placed in the intensive care
unit. The
chest x-rays showed fluid in the tissues of
both lungs
that possibly was pneumonia and the heart
was enlarged.
Erin's blood oxygen worsened during the night
and she
suffered a cardiac arrest. But after a few
minutes of
resuscitation, her heart was beating again
and her
breathing continued to be supported by the
machine.
Stunned, Glenda and I sat in the waiting area
throughout
the night trying to remain supportive of each
other. So
I won't go into more detail about all that
just at the
moment. But Erin then had a horrendous course
but
survived. And required some heart surgeries
and lots of
other things. Which make for a short but quite
interesting series of anecdotes. And then,
I put in some
photos including, of Erin as she graduated
from high
school and later got married to her college
sweetheart.
So it all turns out well. But those sorts
of surprises
can overtake any family. And you need to be
prepared to
deal with that. I had a younger daughter Carley
who was
quite skilled and talented, loved to play
the piano and
was quite good at it. And she, as a young
elementary
student, she performed brilliantly several
complex
classical pieces at her spring piano concert
so I was
dismayed that during the following summer
months -- do she
was in elementary school--, she decided she
would not
practice the piano even one day. In September,
--so the
summer had gone by -- I thought that I would
teach her a
useful lesson about the importance of practice
and
continued effort. I sat her down at a piano
and asked
her to please play her classical pieces from
that prior
spring concert. The smug look dropped from
my face when
Carley effortlessly played them all nearly
perfectly from
memory. So I'm not sure who learned the bigger
lesson
that afternoon. Parents should observe carefully
and
take to heart a real sense of wonder and awe
as their
children grow and develop. Human beings are
truly
amazing. Carley made transitions and so on.
And when
she was about 16 years old, she joined a group
of high
school students who were being trained by
the local
police to go into a bar and order a drink.
If the
student was not properly carded, and was actually
given a
drink, the police waiting outside planned
to move in and serve a
citation. Although Carley was a fairly worldly
teenager, she actually did not have, at that
time, any
experience ordering alcohol. The dozen or
so students
were assembled for an informal training session
that
included a mock-up of a bar area with a policeman
acting
as bartender so the students could practice
what they
were supposed to say. The police instructor
explained
that the bar would have hard liquor as well
as beer in
both bottles and draft. Carley was first at
bat so she
somewhat self-consciously stepped up to the
mock
bartender, feigned a confident attitude, and
in a loud
voice announced, "I'd like a bottle of draft
beer,
please." [laughter] After a second of stunned
silence, the
bartender and all of the police trainers roared
with
laughter. Blinking like a deer in the headlights
and a
little red faced, Carley listened as they
explained her
error. So that gives you some flavor of raising
Carley.
When I was then a young faculty member in
Chicago, I had to
interview students who wanted to come and
be interns and
trainees at our hospital. So I had different
sorts of
interviews. Some were interviews for students
who -- to
get more boots on the ground I would hire
bright students
to come work in my research laboratory for
the summer.
So I -- hospital paid for it so I was happy
to hire them.
And they always made a contribution. It was
fun to be
around bright young students. But there was
an issue. I
had accepted a very bright young coed to join
my lab for
a few weeks. But a month before her scheduled
time, she
called me and explained sheepishly that she
would have to
back out of the job. So this is her on the
telephone.
She said, "I have just won an all expenses
paid trip to
Switzerland for this summer." "Wow," I replied
and I
expressed by sincere congratulations then
I added just in
jest, "but if you stop to reconsider for a
moment,
wouldn't you rather work in my lab in Chicago
doing
fascinating biochemistry rather than traveling
here and
there in Switzerland?" She was silent for
a moment. So
then I added, "and consider Chicago is actually
exactly like
Switzerland only flatter". [laughter] Now
realizing that I was just
teasing her we both had a good laugh together.
In
addition to interviewing college students
for summer
positions, I also interviewed individually
each year about 20 medical
students who were applying to be interns in
the
hospital's internal medicine training program.
I really
enjoyed meeting these bright applicants and
I was quite
interested to see what they were doing with
their lives.
One of my particular points of interest was
to analyze
the chronology of what they had listed on
their
applications so I could understand what they
had done
year by year since high school, a period of
8 years for
these applicants. Sometimes a little probing
would
disclose they had traveled in Europe for a
year or worked
on an archaeological dig. During one interview
with a
muscular young man, I was having difficulty
understanding
what he had done for one 12-month period where
there
seemed to be a gap in his CV. He hemmed and
hawed a bit
and I still had no clarity after a minute
or 2. "So just
tell me," I continued in a mildly stern tone.
"Is that the
year that you were in jail?" His wide eyed
expression
instantly told me --somewhat to my horror--
that I must have
struck a nerve. But let me explain right now
doctor he
blurted that it was not really my fault. We
finished the
rest of the interview in a fairly routine
manner but I'm
sure he walked out, wondered what amazing
investigative techniques
had been employed by the hospital to discover
his secret.
I'd only been joking, of course, when I mentioned
jail. [clears throat] As
a young faculty member I had a research lab
and I loved
my research and I loved publishing papers
and so on, but
the grant process is very competitive and
I got to the
point where I eventually just couldn't compete.
I was a
pretty small operation. I did some good things
working
on TSH and of course later, I came to work
on Genzyme and
they make recombinant human TSH for thyroid
cancer
patients. So I've had 30 years of experience
working on
the biochemistry of TSH. So this was a really
good fit
for me to move to Genzyme . But at the time,
we were
under a lot of stress. And as we were unable
to support
our research, find ways to do it, it was tough
times in
academics. And it still is tough. I loved
a joke that
circulated in our department at that time
that seemed
quite apropos. There once was a remote monastery
of
monks whose goal was to pray three times a
day for the
salvation of the world, help the poor a little
if they
could, and teach young boys how to become
monks. So this
was like a parallel situation to us in academics
where we
weren't supposed to just see patients all
the time -- patients
patients patients -- but we were supposed
to teach and do
research and other things just as the monks
were supposed
to pray for the salvation of the world, help
the poor,
teach young boys how to become monks. The
monks took
pride in being very self-sufficient. So they
tended
small gardens and eked out a living as best
they could.
One day, a bright monk came to the superior
with the idea
that if the monks sold some of the wine they
made each
year, there would be more funds available
to make life
more efficient for the community. Even the
poor could be
helped a little more. The superior approved
the sale of
wine and over the next years, the monastery
sold more and
more wine. Soon it became a booming business.
But a new
superior became concerned as costs of business
rose. And
more and more wine had to be sold to support
the
infrastructure. The superior asked the monks
to pray
less each day, and teach less each day. And
instead,
spend more time making wine. After a few more
years, the
superior reached a crucial decision. In order
to meet
the new quotas for the next year's wine deliveries,
the
praying and the teaching would have to stop
completely. So
that was our joke at the University and then
shortly
after that, I left the University and I joined
as some
people said the dark side of the biotech industry
where
we were trying to do clinical research to
invent new
drugs to make money but also, of course, to
help patients.
That sort of innovation is critical to have
new drugs
that will cure diseases. Okay. So we're coming
to the
end. I put a chapter in about the importance
of making
and saving money and investing. And it's not
just to buy
the fancy cars. Having a little extra money
in the bank
gives you the independence to go to the job
you want to
go to even if it's not the best-paying job
or to move to
the city that you want to move to even if
it's not the
best-paying situation. It also allows you
to tell your
boss, "that's a good idea but I actually see
it this way
and so please consider looking at it this
way." Maybe
you don't have that issue at Google, but in
many places
you do have that issue. And if you are not
just worried
every minute about what your job review is
going to be
and so on it just gives you a little more
independence in
terms of -- not that you're being insolent
or a
troublemaker, but it just affects the way
that you can
handle yourself in certain difficult situations.
So the
the money is not the end. It's a tool. A very
important
tool. And so, some people almost go the other
direction
where they want to be completely non-materialistic
and I'm
note going to save my money and so on but
you have to
realize, as a responsible person in our culture,
you have
to have savings and investments. And that
gives you the
ability to be relatively independent of forces
that are
trying to control you, okay? So I put -- of
course, I've
counseled over the years many medical students
and
trainees and they're worried about all the
hard work.
They're worried about how I can make a living
in the
future. What should I do? I have a girlfriend
in San
Francisco. How is this going to work out with
my
training and so I would work with them. But
one of the
key things I would always talk with them about
was saving
and investing and trying to save money. And
I loved the
auto biography of Benjamin Franklin. So let
me just read
a little bit from Chapter 19 about that. So
I've made
the widely known points earlier about saving
and
investing sensibly. They're the true keys
to
accumulating wealth. But there are also other
important
tidbits to mention. One must study hard, work
hard, and
make the proper connections so as to optimize
one's
earning potential. An entertaining and very
readable
account along those lines has been given to
us by
Benjamin Franklin in his autobiography. Although
this
selection might sound formidable, his autobiography
is
actually a slim paperback volume that can
be purchased about 10
dollars new. He wrote the first part when
he was -- and
then he was interrupted so he completed the
last part in
old age. Actually many scholars believe the
book was not
finished. The somewhat old fashioned language
takes only
ten pagers or so to get used to and the authenticity
is
well-worth this minor inconvenience. Frugality
is but
one of many topics addressed. He was willing
to leave
home, travel to many places, expertise at
reading and
writing was vital, he was willing to serve
on committees
and do other unpopular jobs of that kind since
he actually then
could have a direct hand in shaping outcomes
of important
relevant questions. Notable was Franklin's
skill at
being in the right place so as to be the obvious
choice
when some task had to be done for a fee such
as printing
up paperwork for the legislature. His personal
reflections
on trying to be a good person and his record-keeping
of
sins are delightful accounts. Many educators
would
assert this is one book that every American
should read
or anyone of any nationality really and it
could be read
in just a few days or during a couple of airplane
rides. And so,
I list that book in an appendix that's on
Page 173 of
what I would recommend at least for people
interested in
science and medicine as key books that might
be of
interest for let's say holiday reading or
summer time
reading and they include the Double Helix
by James
Watson. A great book is the Discoveries by
Alan
Lightman. The Discovery of Insulin by Michael
Bliss is a
good book. A collection of little funny anecdotes
that are each
about a page long is Eurekas and Euphorias
by Gratzer. That's a
great book especially for airplane reading
because each anecdote is like a page,by famous
scientists, Tesla,
Einstein. I like space and things. So I put
some books
on about the great inner planetary missions,
sending robots out to other planets. Amir
D. Aczel,
who I think is in New England, wrote a book
called the
Mystery of the Aleph. There's a book at the
end, When Bad Things
Happen to Good People, which I bought and
read when my
first daughter was very, very sick. And of
course was
having many bad things happen to her. So what
does it
mean when bad things happen to good people?
And in
closing, I'm going to leave a little time
for some
questions. I added a chapter that's only three
pages.
But these are my closing thoughts. And of
course, this
book was intended to be about chess, yes,
and there are
lots of examples about chess games and strategies
for
trying to trick and win some chess games.
But the book
was intended to be more about chess. I go
on to say
anecdotes can be entertaining but also instructive
and
helpful. My hope is that a thoughtful reader
might glean
practical advice from my ramblings that will
prove useful in other areas of life
. And I actually have another appendix
where I give specific advice because I've
worked with
medical students, trainees and of course,
two daughters
and so I tell them to wear sunscreen, wear
a hat, take
calcium and vitamin D every day. Money is
very
important, but don't be overly materialistic.
Money is a
tool, not an end and so on. So I put lots
of things that
I hope people -- young people -- would see
value in some
of those things just like for my recommended
books. You
can't read all these books, but if you pick
three or four
of them to look at. These are not my books.
They're
books I recommend that I think would be of
real value to
bright young people who are interested in
science or
medicine. I talk about, you know, what does
it mean if
we're faced with a world full of suffering
and which many
people claim, I mean, that there's no ultimate
meaning to
any of this anyway. So what's the point of
all this?
Why don't we just go out and get drunk? So
I quote Isaac
Newton. And also one of my favorite authors
Loren Eiseley
who probably if you pick one book off my list
to read and
it's easy to read. It's not highly technical.
It's an
old book a couple of decades ago. The Immense
Journey is
a very easy book to read. So I guess the autobiography
of Benjamin Franklin and the Immense Journey
by Loren
Eiseley. Are very thoughtfully written entertaining
books. So Newton was a brilliant, creative,
a loner, a
supremely hard worker who was willing to pursue
scientific calculations day and night without
food or
sleep. But he also was concerned about ultimate
understandings. And in his treatise Optics
published in
1794 he criticized other scientists who were
trying to
banish God, the first cause as he viewed it,
from a proper
understanding of the world. Newton writes
"latter
philosophers", meaning our current thinkers
now, "banish the
consideration of a cause out of natural philosophy,"
he
wrote. Feigning hypotheses for explaining
all things
mechanically and referring all other causes
to metaphysics.
But Newton viewed this purely mechanical approach
as
flawed. Newton instead wanted to deduce causes
from
effects till we come to the very first cause.
He was
comfortable with gravity's mysterious action
at a
distance, for example, and was content to
describe how
gravity acted in mathematical detail while
admitting the precise mechanisms whereby gravity
exerts its effects, remain completely unexplained.
Newton
wanted not merely to unfold the mechanism
of the world
but he also wanted to learn, "whence is it
that nature doth nothing in vain and whence
arises all that order
order and beauty which we see in the world."
And
then Eiseley, I'll just close on a couple
quotes from him. Eiseley
who was a 20th century anthropologist and
naturalist, echoes some of
Newton's longings for ultimate understanding.
Eiseley
writes there's no logical reason for the existence
of a
snow flake any more than for evolution. It
is an
apparition from the final world which contains,
if
anything contains, the explanation of men
and cat fish and
green leaves. Eiseley was not enamored of
organized
religion but his keen scientific mind also
encompassed a
profound mystical sense. Quote, "Man is not
as other creatures," he
observed. "Without the sense of the holy,
without
compassion, his brain can become a gray stalking
horror.
The divisor of Belsen". So I would like to
close
now to entertain a couple of questions. I
would
encourage you to, you know, take a copy. Share
it with a
friend. Buy six more copies, you know, I make
I think 59
cents for each copy that's sold. I've tried
to write a
book under the guise of a chess book that
also has, I
think, messages that really would be valuable
to let's say
college age students or young trainees that
deserve, even
if they don't like what I write, if they'll
look at the
appendix and look at some of the books I recommend
I
think there would be a lot of value here for
a pretty
slim book. So let me close there. Thank you
again for
your attention. I'd be happy to answer any
questions.
[Applause]